deux danseuses qui zozote yade et mika
sur un jeu d'horreur en ligne bonjour
bonjour
mika aujourd'hui on est sur l'adrias
marge d'erreur en ligne voilà
aujourd'hui on va se faire peur avec les
copains ça va être drôle et ya fait sur
prêts joubert à japy pas le jeu est très
simple à chaque début drones ya un mec
qui est le fantôme l'esprit et de mecs
qui sont les humains et le but des
humains et de fuir l'esprit pour pas
devenir eux-mêmes des esprits voilà les
humains ils ont de pouvoir ils peuvent
faire un clone de hum voilà comme ça et
là y'a un truc à bloquer sa patte en moi
je sais qu'il est là tu vois coupe et il
eut place moi je suis pas là je suis là
je suis là a juste la victoire
du coup je peux matricielle
avant-première de obama tu touches la
porte je t'apporte j'te jure c'est du
vrai bois dégage pour le moment ce qui
fait le plus peur du jeu voilà c'est à
dire je prends un chien alors qu'elle a
c'est qui ça c'est un leurre sais pas
mais j'ai voulu bbb tu fais quoi de
bouder les escaliers mobiles via lille
était tendue que dans les jeux où le
propos valeur mon gars attention le plan
des bolides de vikash sûr que ça lâche
pas la vache au label machette cours il
reste 45 secondes pour nos buts et je
crois qu'on va gagner y allons attendre
du coup mais j'ai regardé ça j'en sais
me jean pasaia ben oui
c'est dorian talking droit pour aller at
on regarde je prends le petit bébé en
rock en ce printemps la fa cup j'ai
toujours en visio ok j'en vois une unité
terrestre s'est tu peux t'arrêter de
jouer iata mais quel collègue ça embête
et policiers a fait son travail
oh [ __ ] la ja lemay leur spectre du
monde qui nous suit mec feria t'aurais
pas leur nom parce qu'il admire leur il
s'est fait doubler non appuyé par y vas
tu es là il va rentrer dans l'ascenseur
on fédère ont fait des grandes choses
monsieur diallo mécanique a été tout le
temps et ça on est mort ouais c'était
quoi faire pipi
le chien pendant toilettes toi ami de
toi tu es qu'il va revenir plat on
devrait d'olive juste la regarde et
attend elle fait pas pipi lasse pas
possible quoi olive attends moi je vais
de l'autre côté il aura l'air est plus
gros qu'une pièce de deux euros
ce que total olive est comme ça moi j'ai
la saucisse boudin il est long n'est
allé nulle vigueur
c'est la verte est alors mais tu fais
gaffe parce que là pour le coup le jeu a
décidé de mettre le plus gros fantôme de
tous les temps sur notre dos respecte
mais c'est tellement bien mec quand au
moment où la clique qui peut pas
scéniques marche et ce qu'ils m'ont fait
une petite que j'ai lus par contre si
[Musique]
j'arrête tout atar ya de vieux bb&t va
rentrer là j'ai mal lu mon chauffeur
s'il n'avait pas fait ça va voir j'ai
une idée de malade mon gars tu es prêt à
les allégements que j'occupe unités
volantes oblats voilà mettez volant je
m'en suis occupé j'aurais pas de stock
bien bien aussi je retourne en
patrouille a tenté de dire
j'arrive les garçons n'y avait-il alors
c'est quoi ce sprint 2000 sérieux on
peut même pas avancer là bas j'en déduis
que yann où est mort sucré salé au sucré
salé à n'est pas prêt ce qui les oppose
sandisk est ok je te donne un pic à je
vous débat intitulé [ __ ] mais calmes
et et [ __ ] d'égoïste quoi je te plaît
chez lui et il y aura bien des choses eh
bien je trouve des types dans la balle
je deviens pro tu n'as un jour mon
prince coucou c'est quoi ce jeu où tu
peux faire faire des crises cardiaques à
tes potes quoi c'est marrant j'ai eu
aucun mec va toujours au même endroit et
chalon il fait tout le temps la même
chose ne me regarde quoi il fait ce pays
fait des ip des bagarres elle fait des
chenils de mec est un véritable musée
avec nous que fait il fait quoi il est
rare et penser mais ou alors c'est bien
son petit fils aîné jean et là j'ai eu
bien du talent je mets du talc voilà les
cas je peux tu un câble je pète un câble
je pète les plombs [ __ ] je pète les
plombs
hp est un chat parce que c'est pas un
jeu de merde non pas dans les blocs par
ianu safetic titre et voilà c'est la fin
de cette gamme de cette vidéo
merci dit yan tu es là vous avez demandé
est indisponible actuellement la magic
mouse et pas un numéro
[ __ ] drobo ca mais a un nom ya
l'euskal que bon merci à vous d'avoir
fait cette vidéo sur ce jeu un peu
moisie avec moi c'était très agréable
aux autres maintenant d'une prochaine
vidéo merci d'avoir gardé ne sais pas
mais les deux ça vous a plu
je parle encore publie tout partenariat
tant pis
[Musique]